language the happy time murders so to
say that I had been waiting for this
movie to come out for a long time is an
understatement
my memories a little hazy and I could be
wrong about this but to my memory I
first heard about Brian Henson trying to
fund this project back when I was still
in college so we're talking over a
decade ago I remember first hearing
about this project so that's a lot of
anticipation waiting for this thing to
finally get made and the initial
trailers gave me a lot to worry about
because I didn't know what I was
necessarily hoping for but it really did
look from the trailers like it was going
to be nothing but a raunchy comedy that
was with puppets and many of the jokes
aren't that different from what it would
have been done in a raunchy comedy over
a decade ago when this thing was
originally planned they just happen to
be doing it with puppets
and having now seen the film that is
largely the case and yet somehow I was
okay with that which is weird cuz I
really picky about comedy especially
gimmicky comedy like to me the epitome
of a gimmick any gimmick comedy gimmick
you know sci-fi gimmick what-have-you is
if you remove that gimmick is this a
very bog-standard thing that you just
slapped a gimmick on to I mean that's
what you get with a lot of say like
found-footage horror movies most of them
are not telling anything new in the
horror genre they just slap a
found-footage gimmick on it or I
mentioned this where I talked about
quiet night in the inside number 9
episode that a lot of people love but if
you remove the gimmick of the fact that
it's nearly silent what it's doing is
really very run-of-the-mill and in many
ways that is the case here so I don't
know if it's just a matter of I love the
gimmick so much like I I just I I love
puppets I've always loved puppets and
I've always had a special
place in my heart for the henson level
of puppetry it was one of the things
that actually made it really hard for me
to get through Peter Jackson's film from
earlier called meet the Feebles which is
probably a better movie in terms of you
know having a bit more as mind the level
of subversion and the sorts of things
going on yet I enjoyed it much less and
I think a big part of what continually
took me out of that was the the level of
puppets puppetry was not up to part of
what I was used to and I don't even
necessarily mean how the puppets
themselves look I mean the the way they
moved the way they act the way they
speak the the physicality of them I was
raised on Henson puppetry and when
puppetry is not up to that standard
it can oftentimes take me out of it and
it did with meet the Feebles but it drew
me in here now I had not seen like the
Rotten Tomatoes score or anything else
before going to see this I made a
deliberate choice not to because I
already knew that I was nervous going in
so I was really afraid that if I saw
what the critics were saying that it was
kind of completely taint my my viewing
of the thing and the critics seem to be
rather rough on this and it seems like a
decent number of audience members are
too and I have to wonder if that has to
do with expectations because the the
obvious point of comparison for somebody
this would be Who Framed Roger Rabbit a
new frame Roger Rabbit in addition to
being a technological marvel also had a
lot on its mind it very deliberately
paralleled the the tunes and through its
period setting and some of the specifics
to black entertainers of that same time
where they were performing in spaces
they themselves were not allowed in and
sort of how they were treated as
entertainers and second-class citizens
there's like a tiny bit of that here but
it's not it's not there as a subversion
it's there because all the humans hate
the puppets allows for them to not have
to explain a lot of the jokes otherwise
because it just allows for the human
characters to treat the puppets like
crap so here there is a puppet that
second-class citizens thing but it's not
too
point it doesn't work as a direct
allegory for anything honestly it
doesn't work as a class allegory it
doesn't work as a race allegory although
it has elements of all those things in
there but ultimately the only reason
puppets are prejudiced against are
because it allows for a whole bunch of
the humor that happens to this to go
otherwise I'm explained because if you
don't just establish well humans treat
puppets like crap then you'd have to
explain on a character by character
basis why all these people are treating
puppets like crap
so they remove that complication by just
saying I'm all most humans treat pups
like crap and then you just move on but
again I wonder if people were expecting
this to have a bigger point when it
doesn't and it doesn't pretend to either
there's really no pretension in this
which I kind of appreciated while I do
love something like Who Framed Roger
Rabbit that has a deeper point it has
levels that you can read into and that's
wonderful but when you do that and it
doesn't work you just end up with
pretentious and that is really grating
and I would rather have something that
rather than having pretensions that I
can't deliver on just is what it is and
owns it which I think this does and
another thing that honestly went a long
way for me is Melissa McCarthy who is a
performer I am very up-and-down on I
don't hate her I've never hated her but
she's rarely done much for me she has
the best performance chemistry with the
main puppet Phil Phillips in this that
I've seen her have with any performer
she plays off of him so well why and I
loved seeing the two of them together
I love Phil Phillips actually he's
probably my favorite character because
he is he is just a grizzled noir Private
Eye stereotype who happens to be a
puppet and again I wonder people were
expecting them to like play against the
grain of that but there's something
about the fact that he's playing it
straight and like he's not he's not a
puppet eep uppity Zinn you know he's got
very limited expression his mouth just
basically just opens and closed and he
doesn't do the big you know big
exaggerated things he's just kind of
like well isn't this just a heck of a
day
kind of thing and it works and it stays
entertaining and his reactions always
feel very real you know he also said he
walks into emergencies like what dumb
thing y'all wait he'll swear and I won't
because I don't wanna have to bleep that
many things but you know I his his
reactors feel very genuine and the fact
that they're coming from a puppet make
it work for me it makes it work a little
bit more than a would otherwise um as
far as plot goes it's it's pretty
boilerplate new AR and it does work as a
straight noir story it borrows that sort
of thing in terms of you know your your
dwindling roster of suspects and you
know trying to figure out what could the
motivation be and the misdirections and
the you know and the characters who's
playing who against who and that
nobody's really a particularly good
person across the board and it's it's
doing all that stuff again pretty much
straight just with puppets and ie I
don't want to overpraise this it's not
an amazing movie by any means but just
think of it as the fact that I had over
a decade of anticipation for this thing
and I wasn't disappointed it didn't like
blow my expectations away but it it was
what I have wanted this movie to be
since I first heard about it
it's a raunchy you know gritty story
with puppets that's what I wanted that's
what I got so I think if you can keep
your expectations in check it pretty
much works there are a few jokes that
don't land especially well but
thankfully it's brisk enough then it
keeps a good enough pace that generally
a joke landing flat doesn't doesn't just
sit there forever I think the one big
exception is there's a running gag where
people keep either jokingly or
mistakenly saying that Melissa McCarthy
looks like a man which she doesn't like
at all and I was saying she's incapable
of looking like a man but she just she
doesn't look like a man she's not a
particularly feminine woman but she
doesn't look like
guy so I don't know why they made a
running joke out of that cuz it just it
doesn't run
they made a stumbling joke out of that
that just keeps stumbling into the into
frame again not entirely sure why they
did that but that's like the only thing
that stuck out in my mind is being like
boy that didn't work and if I wanted to
be nitpicky at it I couldn't it pick a
lot of stuff in it but I don't want to
and I know I can be nitpicky I know I
have a tendency to do that but every now
and then something comes along that just
kind of makes me happy and I know it's
not great art and if I was in a
vindictive move mood I couldn't it
picked the heck out of it but I don't
want to because I enjoyed it I don't
feel like undercutting that that's
basically where I land here so the happy
time murders I get the in the idea that
I have much higher opinion at this movie
than a lot of people seem to but I
enjoyed it I think it's one that if
you've been seeing the critic responses
and subbing me oh I won't watch that if
you're like me you grew up on Henson
level puppetry I say give it a shot I
mean know what you're getting into know
what it is nobody isn't and I I think
it's it's worth a go because even if you
just appreciate Henson style puppetry
it's got that and it's as good as it is
in you know anything else so I that's
not nothing so the happy time murders
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's also a bunch of
buttons and links including one to the
patreon so check those out if you care
so remember folks you are the council I
just friend the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]